- I normally like to start these sessions
with a little bit of interaction.
So indulge me for one second.
Hands up if you knew that
almost every professional
or semi-professional football team,
professional team or individual athlete
use some form of wearable device
to track their data either
in game or in practice.
Okay, significantly more than
I thought there would be.
Maybe you've thought
about what type of data
they're ingesting or
what type of analytics
can be generated on that data.
But maybe you haven't thought about
who actually makes these devices
and the market that they serve.
Well, that's what we're here
to talk to you about today.
And for those that
didn't raise their hand,
I hope today you can see
a different side of sport,
one that's fueled by data.
So my name's Mike,
and I'm a Sports Solution
Architect based in Australia.
And with me, I have Greg,
one of our Senior IoT
Specialist Solution Architects.
And today, we'll be talking
about one of my customers,
Catapult Sports.
And I'll refer to them as Catapult
throughout the rest of the presentation.
We'll be talking about who
they are, what they do,
and how they're transforming sport.
We'll talk about athlete data ingestion.
What are they ingesting?
How are they doing it?
And then what can be done with that data
once it's been ingested?
What type of analytics, metrics,
and improvements to athlete
performance can be given?
We'll go a bit deeper into the
device software architecture
and how they've used AWS to
build their wearable devices.
We'll talk about device onboarding,
how they manage updates,
and how they can roll out
different types of configuration.
And finally, we'll look to the future.
What can Catapult do next
to continue evolving
data in the sports world?
Now, I've mentioned Catapult,
so let me introduce you to who they are.
Catapult exists to unleash the potential
of every athlete and team in the world.
Operating at the cross-section
of sports science and analytics,
Catapult products are designed
to optimize performance,
improve recoverability, and
quantify return to play.
Now, the business is listed
on the Australian Securities
Exchange and has over 400 staff
based across 24 different
locations worldwide.
But rather than tell you
throughout the presentation
who they are and what they do,
how about a little video to set the scene
and contextualize this?
(intense music)
Great.
So within that video, I'm gonna
refer to a couple of things
that you might have seen.
Now, Catapult has a number
of different solutions,
and we don't have time
to cover all of them,
but I'll touch on three,
and we'll go into depth into
one of them specifically today.
First, we have athlete monitoring.
Now, you may have seen in the video
there was a little device that was put
into a vest that one of
the players was wearing.
Now, this is designed
to optimize performance,
reduce the risk of injury,
and improve recovery.
And this is what we'll
dive deep into today.
The second solution is the
scouting and recruiting.
This is designed to find, evaluate,
and acquire the right
players for your team.
And finally, to bring context to data,
Catapult has a video suite offering.
And this connects the data to video
to transform strategy,
performance, and training.
Now, before we dive deep
into the athlete monitoring solution,
let's take a little bit of
a look at Catapult's market.
Now, Catapult operates in
over 128 different countries,
has customers in over 40 different sports,
and has over 5,000 elite
teams as their customer.
Now, Catapult's customers include
some of the biggest clubs
and franchises in the world,
from the NFL to the NHL to
the English Premier League.
And here is an example of the top sports
that Catapult have customers in.
Now, diving a little bit
into the athlete monitoring capabilities
that Catapult provide,
Catapult tracks comprehensive
performance metrics
that give coaches actionable insights
for training and competition.
Now, I wanna specifically
touch on a couple of these.
Player load is one that we'll
dive a bit deeper into later,
but it quantifies the
total physical stress.
Now, this is a primary tool
for workload management
and injury prevention across a season.
Next, we have speed zones.
Speed zones categorize athlete output
across velocity, thresholds,
helping us understand game demands
and prescribe appropriate
train intensities.
Now, for those that love
their contact sports,
contact intensity measures
collision forces in those sports.
And this is important for
managing player safety
and recovery needs.
And finally, something very important
is that Catapult can identify
sport-specific movements,
such as jumps, tackles, and throws.
Now, these are automatically
detected and quantified,
providing tailored insights
for those 40-plus sports
that I mentioned earlier.
Now, together, these metrics
enable data-driven decisions
that optimize performance
while keeping athletes healthy
and ready to compete.
And with that, I wanna introduce Vector 8.
Now, Vector 8 is Catapult's
next-gen solution
for athlete monitoring,
designed for both elite and
competitive sports environments.
Now, Vector 8 consists
of four main components.
First, we have the Vector 8 tag,
and this is what was shown in the video.
It is compact, rugged, and
packed with advanced features.
It uses GNSS and local positioning
for precise location tracking,
and it works seamlessly
indoors and outdoors.
It captures sport-specific events,
monitors heart rate,
processes data onboard,
and supports integration
with third-party Bluetooth
and ultra-wideband UWB sensors,
and offers up to six
hours of battery life.
Now, ultra-wideband, or UWB,
for those that don't know,
is a wireless communication technology
that uses short-range,
low-power radio signals
to enable precise location tracking
and secure data transfer.
Now, it's important to
note that each athlete
has their own Vector 8 tag.
The Vector 8 dock is used
post-session or post-match,
and the tag gets placed
back into the dock.
Now, the Vector 8 dock
enables fast Wi-Fi downloads
and effortless data syncing
directly to the cloud.
It supports easy workflows,
manages devices locally or remotely,
and its onboard computing
means you can use it anywhere
without the need for additional equipment.
Next, we have the Vector 8 receiver.
Now, this connects via
both Wi-Fi and ethernet,
and it streams live data to
the cloud for instant analysis,
supports both online
and offline workflows,
and provides real-time diagnostics
for performance and troubleshooting.
Finally, we have the Vector 8 relay,
and this increases coverage
across larger venues,
eliminating the need
for multiple receivers.
It boasts a 400-meter
range in a compact form,
making scalable deployments
efficient and cost-effective.
Now, together, these
components make Vector 8
a powerful suite for
collecting, streaming,
and analyzing athlete data,
advancing both training and
in-game decision-making.
Now, I wanna talk about how they do this,
and this is where I introduce our
first AWS service of the day.
AWS IoT Core is a managed service
that provides scalable and
highly available endpoint
in the cloud, meaning you
have an endpoint there
so you don't need to create
one for every device.
It provides device
authentication and authorization,
encryption in transit,
device management at scale,
which is crucial for Catapult's use case,
and then, most importantly,
the rules engine.
Now, the rules engine is
how you glue the application
to the data coming through to IoT Core.
The rules engine is the
bind between IoT Core
and your application to manage
a large fleet of devices,
ranging in the thousands
to tens of thousands.
That's what makes this a great service
to underpin Catapult's
Vector 8 technology,
and Greg will go into more detail later on
on the extent that they use it.
Now, before we dive a bit deeper
into how Catapult does this,
I wanna talk about the
different ingestion paths
and the different type of data
that Catapult can collect.
First, we have the device health.
Now, this is the battery
status in the firmware version
of the Vector 8 tag itself.
We then have hot data.
Now, this is live, in-game,
or in-practice data
that's sampled at 10 hertz,
and this includes things
like acceleration,
velocity, player positioning,
and heart rate monitoring.
Finally, we have the cold data.
Now, this is post-game or post-practice,
and it is raw inertial
data sampled at 100 hertz,
and this makes the basis of
the machine learning inference
that Catapult runs.
They do it on the cold
data in a batched approach
rather than streaming it
through to the hot data.
But what does this look like?
So let's start with the device health,
and this is during a game or practice.
Now, this slide illustrates
the real-time device health
monitoring architecture,
and this is a critical operational feature
for maintaining fleet reliability
during live games and practice.
Now, it starts with the
player wearing a Vector 8 tag,
and then their data, or the
data that's been ingested,
is transmitted by UWB to
the Catapult receiver.
Now, the receiver's on the sideline,
meaning there is low latency
and high-precision tracking.
From the receiver, this
publishes device telemetry
via MQTT to AWS IoT Core.
This creates a secure,
scalable ingestion pipeline
that can handle data
from hundreds of devices simultaneously.
Now, AWS IoT Rules engine
processes incoming messages
and routes them to Amazon MSK,
our managed Kafka service,
for real-time streaming and buffering,
ensuring we never lose
critical device health data.
Now, from MSK, data flows
to Amazon Elastic
Container Service, or ECS,
where Catapult's containerized
analytics services run.
Now, this process has battery
levels, firmware versions,
and other diagnostics in real-time.
Results are exposed
through Amazon API Gateway
and delivered to the
Catapult web interface.
This is where coaches
and equipment managers
can monitor device status at a glance.
Now, an example of a payload
is there on the screen.
We can see battery, we can
see the firmware version,
and this enables proactive intervention
before devices fail
during critical moments.
Now, prior to AWS IoT, Catapult
lacked the observability
of device status, health, and usage.
Now, they have that in
real-time for every device.
Now, this AWS-powered architecture
ensures high availability, scalability,
and real-time visibility
into the entire device fleet,
minimizing downtime and maximizing
performance reliability.
Let's take a look at the hot data.
Now, this architecture delivers
real-time athlete
performance done at 10 hertz,
as previously mentioned,
or 10 updates per second.
And this enables coaches to
make split-second decision
during games and practices.
And there are inertial
sensors on the tags,
as mentioned previously,
for precise positioning and tracking.
Now, the tags transmit
via UWB to the receiver
and then stream data to the mobile devices
and web applications.
Now, the payloads are
updated in real-time,
and here is a small example.
As you can see, there's a heart rate,
the position, the velocity,
and the acceleration.
Now, coaches can see
instant visualizations
on their iOS apps.
They can see player workload comparisons,
positioning heat maps,
and individual metrics on these devices.
This enables in-the-moment interventions,
substituting fatigued players,
adjusting tactics based
on movement patterns,
and preventing injuries
before they happen.
Finally, we have the cold data.
And this is the post-game, post-practice,
sampled at 100 hertz.
And this is what Catapult uses
to run their ML inference on.
Now, just to put some numbers in the air,
a two-hour session with 30 athletes
can upload to S3 in less than 30 seconds.
To put even more numbers
on, let's take an NHL game.
Assume it's a two-and-a-half-hour game,
20 athletes each side, so 40 athletes,
all wearing Vector 8 tags,
and inertial data that's
sampled at 100 hertz.
That's 900,000 data points per athlete
in that two-and-a-half-hour game,
which means 36 million
data points are captured
in a two-and-a-half-hour game.
We've spoken about the ingestion of data,
and what this looks
like, and how it's done.
And I wanna talk about now
what happens after that data's ingested.
Now, I'm gonna mention some metrics,
but we don't have the time
for me to mention all of them,
as Catapult can create 600 unique metrics
per player per game.
Now, I'm gonna put up on the screen
a couple of different sports,
and a couple of the different
sport-specific metrics
that can be captured per each sport,
and I'll let you have a little read of it.
But Vector 8 delivers AI-driven,
sports-specific live data,
so coaches can monitor athlete
output in any environment.
This is essentially automated
performance insights,
and Catapult runs its
machine learning algorithms
on top of the cold data,
and processes large data
sets quickly and accurately
to identify trends and patterns
that might be missed by the human eye.
Now, these sports-specific
movements are very important,
but I wanna think about it
from the coach's perspective.
I have some customers back in Australia
that prior to using Catapult,
spent over eight hours a weekend
looking through video, just coding events.
Post-implementation of Catapult,
that's almost, they've
almost halved the time taken
by being able to identify
these events automatically,
not through video, but just through tags.
And I'll get to it a bit later on,
on what happens when
you can intersect data
that is collected from
these devices and video.
Now, one metric I spoke about
earlier was player load,
and you might be wondering
why we've just entered a math session,
and for anyone who has done math,
the minuses are not meant to be subscript,
they're meant to be subtractions.
But let me define player load,
and then let me contextualize
what this means.
So player load is the
sum of the accelerations
across all axes of the
internal triaxial accelerometer
during movement.
That's a lot of words.
This was originally developed
by the Australian Institute of Sport
with Rugby Union as a customer in mind.
And it's important to know
that the output of this
is just in arbitrary units.
This is a volume measurement.
It is how much work a player has done.
This can be used to compare
players to each other,
or it can be used to compare
a player's workload over time
to see how they're returning from injury
or whether they are
tracking towards an injury.
Now, it has advantages over
using something like distance
as an effort metric,
because it can accumulate during tackles,
ruck work, and non-running activities
or off-the-ball activities.
To contextualize, I'm
gonna use an example.
I love tennis, I'm a big tennis player.
Hopefully there are some
others in the crowd.
Let's assume I'm coming back from injury
and my player load for a session is 200.
Like I said, arbitrary unit.
The effort that I had
for that session was 200.
Coach is happy, I'm happy,
my performance looked pretty good.
The next session, my
player load is now 300.
So I'm working 50% harder
than I was in the previous session.
But my output has dropped a little bit.
So this can identify a couple things.
I'm working harder, but
my performance is worse.
Maybe I'm not ready to
come back from injury,
or maybe I've aggravated
something as well.
Now I wanna be very clear, this
is not a definitive metric.
This is something that can be used
as an input to other statistics.
It can be used as an input
metric with rhetoric,
how did I feel during the game,
or it can be used with other stats.
Now a customer of mine in Australia
started implementing this,
and they decided to delay
the return of a player
by a number of weeks,
'cause they noticed that their player load
was continuously higher
when they had come back
from injury earlier,
but their output was
significantly less than normal.
Like I said, this is a volume measure
and an example of how much effort
a player has put into a session or a game.
And speaking of effort,
Catapult provides effort
breakdown reports.
And this consists of three main sections.
We have effort profiles,
which is each acceleration
of velocity event
per player that is tracked,
and we'll see what this
looks like in a second.
We have effort location mapping,
and this is a visual representation,
and we'll use soccer as
an example in a second,
around where exactly on a field or pitch
has that effort occurred.
And finally, we have the velocity traces.
Now coaches can visualize
how speed builds and fades
across each individual
effort for each player.
But let's see what this looks like.
Now there's a lot happening on the screen,
but I wanna focus on the
bottom left area first.
Now this is a detailed
profile of every effort.
Each acceleration or velocity
event is analyzed by duration,
peak intensity, and recovery time
to help understand the physiological load
and tactical purpose of each effort.
To the right, you'll see a soccer pitch.
Now this is the effort location mapping.
Coaches can view exactly where each effort
occurred on the field.
Now this brings context
to high-speed movements
and context to the effort
profiles on the left.
And finally, we have the
high-resolution velocity trace.
Now with access to a 10
hertz raw velocity trace,
practitioners can clearly
see how speed builds
and fades across each effort.
Now this supports deeper quality control
and a better understanding
of the player's output.
Now effort breakdown
gives coaches the tools
to move from assumption to precision.
By turning raw movement
into actionable insight,
teams can design smarter drills,
manage workload with greater control,
and ensure players are executing
exactly what the game demands.
Now in the video earlier,
you may have seen a screen similar to this
being played through.
Now it's important to note
that that wearable data
without any context or video
is essentially just noise.
It can be used for analytics,
but it can't really explain
what happened on the pitch.
So what does Vector 8 do?
Vector 8 automatically pushes
athlete performance data
into Catapult's Pro Video suite.
This allows users to align physical output
with what actually happened
on the pitch or field.
Coaches and analysts can review, tag,
and explain moments of
interest immediately,
improving athlete
understanding and engagement.
You can capture,
synchronize, and live stream
multi-angle video on any
device from any location.
This is a way of integrating
player performance
to data, to video, to uncover new context
to team and player performance.
The fusion of video and
wearable athlete data
is changing the way that
people think about sport.
It is helping back decision-making,
it is helping quantify return to play,
and hopefully in the future
it'll be able to prevent injury.
Now we've spoken about Catapult,
we've spoken about the
data that they can ingest,
what type of metrics they
can create on top of it,
but let's take a deeper look
into how they leverage AWS to do so.
- Thanks, Mike.
Good afternoon, everyone.
So we're going to dive
a little bit deeper now
into how Catapult are
using AWS IoT services
to build their Vector 8 product,
the benefits they're deriving,
but also the value it's
helping them create
for their customers.
We'll start by looking at
their device software architecture.
AWS IoT Greengrass is a service
that Catapult are using as the foundation
for the Vector 8 dock and receiver.
So to briefly introduce the service,
Greengrass is two things.
It's an edge runtime and a cloud service
that helps you build, deploy, and manage
a multiprocess IoT application at scale.
The edge runtime is open source,
it's available on the cloud,
it's available on GitHub.
The processes or services that you manage
using Greengrass are modeled
as so-called components.
Those components can be
executables, binaries,
scripts, container images,
pretty much any code
that you could otherwise
run on the device you can run
under the control of Greengrass.
As soon as you have a
multiprocess application,
you have dependencies.
Greengrass helps Catapult with that
by supporting component versioning
and component dependency resolution.
It also supports logging for diagnostics.
We have a large collection
of pre-built AWS components
to solve common challenges.
And it has inter-process communication,
IPC for sending messages
between components,
between processes,
but also to access some
advanced Greengrass features,
which I'll talk about shortly.
So, looking at the software architecture
at a very high level, the
architecture of the docks
and the receivers for Vector 8.
At the bottom, we have an
embedded Linux operating system
with the Greengrass edge
runtime sitting just above that,
and it's managing a
multiprocess application
which is comprised of
Catapult custom components
complemented by AWS provided components.
And I'm going to go to some detail
about some of these components.
Moving from the general to the specific,
let's take a look inside the
receiver software architecture.
As you saw earlier with
what Mike showed you
with the data ingestion,
the tags communicate wirelessly
using UWB to the receiver.
Inside the receiver software,
there is the data
processor custom component
developed by Catapult that
is receiving that data.
So that's the device health
data that Mike mentioned,
but also the live data,
the 10 hertz in-game and in-session data.
That data processor component
uses the inter-process
communication feature of Greengrass
to publish the device health
messages to AWS IoT Core
via the Greengrass nucleus,
which is the heart of the
Greengrass edge runtime.
Greengrass includes a message spooler.
And what this is useful for
is if there's any loss of
connectivity for the dock,
if it loses internet connection,
Greengrass can buffer those
device health messages
and send them later when
connectivity is restored.
So this saves Catapult having to build
that undifferentiated
heavy lifting themselves
to just do the buffering and the retries.
Additionally, Catapult
have custom components
that deploy a database, a
RESTful API, and a web server.
And those are used to serve
that 10 hertz live in-game
or in-practice session
data to the iOS apps
that are on the sidelines
that the coaches and the
sports scientists are using.
Moving on to the dock,
as you heard earlier,
when the tags are used with the dock,
they get placed back into the dock.
Part of that's for recharging
as well as for getting data off the tags.
And so when the tags
are placed in the dock,
it's a wired connection, not wireless.
In this case, on the dock,
there's a custom component
called the Retriever component
that is able to go
retrieve that cold data,
that raw 100 hertz post-game data,
and retrieve it as data files
and write that to disk on the dock.
Then the raw file upload custom component
retrieves those data files
and publishes them to
the Amazon S3 bucket.
And as you heard from Mike,
this whole process to get all the data
from all the athletes from one
game or one training session
typically takes just tens of seconds.
Device onboarding or
device first-time setup.
This is a really big topic for Catapult.
For the Vector 8, they had a goal
that onboarding should be
a self-service experience
that enables the customer
to go from unboxing
to athlete tracking in
less than 10 minutes.
To understand why they had that goal,
let's rewind and talk about
how their previous product
generation, the Vector 7,
how it worked for first-time setup.
Vector 7 wasn't a connected product.
It wasn't an Internet of Things thing.
For Catapult's customers,
when they got Vector 7,
they would unbox the device
and they would need to
install a desktop application
on their laptops.
They would then book an appointment
with Catapult customer support,
wait for that appointment to come around,
and then work with customer support
to configure the devices, to
apply any firmware updates
that had been published
since the device was shipped,
and then test and make sure the devices
were in a working state.
It was a long process, typically
in the order of two days,
but at least many hours,
and it was very hands-on
for both Catapult customer support
and also for Catapult's customers.
Now, with Vector 8, the
first-time setup process
is more akin to what you're used to
in setting up any consumer-grade
electronics device.
The customer is unboxing the device,
installing the Catapult
app on their phone,
registering that device within the app,
and that also provisions
the Wi-Fi credentials on the device,
and then the device is able
to connect to the cloud
and automatically pull
down the configuration
and any firmware updates,
and finally publish its status at the end.
From go to woe, a 10-minute process,
no involvement of
Catapult customer support,
and a much more seamless
experience for the customer.
So, good for Catapult and
good for their customers.
In terms of the value that AWS IoT brings,
it's helping with the scale
and the automation of device provisioning,
configuration, updates,
and status reporting.
Okay, so I mentioned device updates,
but there's a lot of detail
there, so let's unpack that.
At AWS, security is job
zero, but in the IoT domain,
I like to say that over-the-air
update is feature zero.
It's the foundation on which
you can build everything else.
If you have over-the-air update,
you can easily add new features
and enhancements to your devices
even after they've shipped to the field.
You're able to easily patch
your devices at scale,
resolving bugs, resolving
customer support issues,
and helping to prevent other customers
from reporting the same issues.
Over-the-air update also
helps to enable innovation
because you're able to
iterate more quickly,
iterate your device software
and help build features
that customers want quickly
in response to customer feedback.
So you saw earlier that
the docks and the receivers
are using Greengrass.
Greengrass supports over-the-air
update out-of-the-box
using a feature called
Greengrass deployments.
Greengrass deployments allow Catapult
to define a set of components
that should be deployed to
a dock or to a receiver.
Some of the components are
shared between the two,
but they also each have
some unique components
'cause they do different things.
With those deployments, it
can target a single device,
but it can also target a group of devices.
So a deployment can operate at scale
by deploying to a large
collection of devices.
It's resilient to
intermittent connectivity.
What this means is when
Greengrass receives a deployment,
it needs to pull down
those component artifacts,
the program binaries,
executables, container images.
If there's any interruption
in the connectivity,
Greengrass will handle all the retries,
all the pausing and the resuming
and get all of those
artifacts to the device,
saving Catapult from having to build
that boilerplate themselves.
Updates are granular.
That means that Greengrass
calculates the delta
between its current state and
what the deployment demands,
and it only downloads what it needs
to make its state match what's
specified in the deployment.
It has rollout and rollback configuration.
If Catapult make a deployment
that includes a faulty component
that fails to start up and
goes into a broken state,
Greengrass will automatically revert
to the previous deployment state,
leaving the dock or receiver
in a good working state,
again, saving Catapult from
having to build that capability.
And finally, it integrates
with operating system updates.
Catapult have done that.
They're able to patch and update
and manage that embedded
Linux operating system
using Greengrass deployments.
Okay, so for the docks and the receivers,
it's straightforward because
it works out of the box
just using what Greengrass offers.
With the tags, it's a
little more complicated.
The tags run FreeRTOS,
they're microcontroller-based devices,
but the UWB interface
they have is bespoke,
a custom protocol, and
so is the wide protocol
when the devices go to the dock.
Consequently, there's something, yeah,
a little more bespoke
for updating the tags.
Catapult begin by making
a Greengrass deployment
to the dock that transfers
the tag firmware binary
from the cloud to the dock.
They then use an AWS
IoT feature called Jobs
to trigger the update process.
The device manager custom
component subscribes
to the necessary MQTT
topics to be notified
of when a job comes in, and
it does that subscription
over the IPC feature
that Greengrass offers.
And then when the tags
are returned to the dock,
the device manager custom
component disseminates
that tag firmware binary
into each of the tags.
So this is powerful for Catapult
because after they create
a deployment in the cloud,
essentially the next time the
tags get returned to the dock,
they will be updated.
So let's talk about
then what is the impact
or the benefit that Catapult are getting
from AWS IoT and the over-the-air updates.
The really big one is compared
to their Vector & product generation,
it's 32 times faster
based on their own data.
A big part of why it's faster
is previously with Vector &,
the customer was in the loop.
They needed to help with their laptops
and that desktop application
to get tags updated.
Now it's an automated process.
As soon as the tags go back
into the dock, they're updated.
Another benefit that comes
from that same reason
is essentially almost
every tag in the fleet
is always running the latest firmware.
If the tag goes back into a dock
after an update's published,
it gets the latest firmware.
The only tags not running latest firmware
are whatever small percentage
just haven't been returned to
a dock for whatever reason.
They're misplaced, they're
lost, so on and so forth.
This aspect is really powerful
because in their previous
product generation,
according to Catapult's
own historical data,
more than 50% of customer
support issues were resolved
just by updating their devices
to the latest firmware.
Now in Vector 8, that
just happens automatically
and hence there's a big collapse
in the number of customer support cases.
That's obviously good for Catapult
and good for their customers.
Over-the-air update also
helps to underpin innovation.
If you want to innovate,
it helps to be able to
rapidly iterate your ideation,
your execution, and your delivery
to have an efficient development process.
So normally you'll ideate and
plan, you'll build new value,
you'll deploy your new
increment, and in an IoT sense,
that means getting it
onto physical devices.
You test, you measure, you update,
you learn, you gather
your customer feedback,
and then you begin the cycle anew.
The quicker that you can
get around this flywheel,
the more enabled you are to innovate.
And as you just saw,
Catapult now with Vector 8
are much faster on the deployment part.
And with that 97% penetration rate,
when they do make a deployment,
it's also getting into the hands
of a lot more customers a lot more quickly
and hence there's more
feedback and more learnings
and more testing happening.
So half of this flywheel
is much more performant
because of the Vector
8 over-the-air updates.
And this put pressure on the
other two parts to be faster.
And in particular, put pressure
on Catapult's firmware team.
So much so that they changed
the way that they worked.
They've swapped now from a
Kanban process to Sprints.
Their release cadence has
moved from months to weeks,
and in some cases, even days,
particularly when developing new features
and doing beta testing.
When they're working with
their beta customers,
they're able to iterate
at very high velocity
to help develop the feature that
the customer actually wants.
And again, that's good for Catapult
and good for their customers.
Okay, device configuration.
Every wearable device has
quite a large collection
of configuration parameters.
And now with the cloud
connectivity available to Catapult,
they're interested in having the tags
also being configured from the cloud,
not needing applications at the edge.
Configuration settings include things
like individual athlete settings,
metric settings relating to
the sport-specific movements,
and also specific requirements
of different teams,
different coaches,
different sports scientists,
and also things like
radio frequency settings
to help tune that wireless communication
between tags and the receivers
in different environments.
Catapult are using an AWS
IoT feature called Shadows
to help them with configuration.
Shadows are JSON documents that AWS IoT
helps you synchronize between
the cloud and your device.
On Greengrass, there is
an AWS-provided component
called Shadow Manager that implements
the device-side part of this feature.
So you can just use it off the shelf
to get shadow functionality
onto your devices,
and that's what Catapult
have done with their docs.
So when a vector web user
modifies the configuration,
the Shadow Manager sees
that the shadow document
in the cloud has changed.
It automatically synchronizes that
to a local shadow database.
The Device Manager custom component
can use the inter-process
communication feature
to retrieve those shadow documents,
and the next time the
tags come back to the doc,
they automatically receive
the latest configuration.
So like the over-the-air update,
you make the change in the cloud.
The next time the tags
come back into the doc,
they get the change.
So the value here for Catapult is
this is quite decoupled now.
Configuration changes
can be made in the cloud,
safe in the knowledge, even
when the doc is offline,
even when the tags are in
use, safe in the knowledge
the next time the tags
are returned to the doc,
they'll get that latest configuration.
There's no customer in the loop anymore.
Previously for configuration updates,
the customer was involved
using their laptop
and desktop application.
They're out of the loop.
It's less burdensome for them.
They can also make configuration changes
for some of the configuration
parameters in the cloud.
It's good for Catapult.
It's good for their customers.
Okay, device diagnostics.
Rewinding again to Vector
7 product generation,
Catapult were relying
heavily on TeamViewer
to be able to reach their
devices for diagnostic purposes.
They would ask their customers
to run TeamViewer on their laptops
so their customer support people
could have a remote session.
Now with AWS IoT, they have the ability
to access their devices
much more directly.
Secure tunneling is an AWS IoT feature
that Catapult are using
for remote SSH sessions
into the docs and the receivers.
And again, there's an
AWS provided component,
a secure tunneling component
that makes it easy to
implement that on your devices
and Catapult are using that
on their docs and receivers.
It's included in their
Greengrass deployments.
Now when a customer support engineer
needs a remote session
with a doc or a receiver,
they go to the AWS
console, create a tunnel,
a notification with a
secure access token is sent,
and the secure tunneling
component creates a tunnel
between the cloud and the SSH daemon
running on the doc or the receiver.
And then the customer support engineer
has an SSH session in place.
Again, the value here, previously,
they had to have the
customer involved hands-on,
team view was involved.
There's no customer appointment anymore,
there's no burden on the customer anymore,
they just need to consent to
Catapult accessing the devices.
Catapult have easy access.
But also, secure tunneling doesn't require
any inbound open ports.
It makes a connection
using a 443 port outbound
and ephemeral inbound ports,
and hence, this also
works behind firewalls.
All of this together,
it's good for Catapult,
it's good for their customers.
And lastly, Log Manager.
Log Manager is another
AWS provided component.
Previously, if Catapult
needed to get to device logs
with their Vector 7, they would, again,
be relying on team viewer
and customer involvement.
Now, with Log Manager, it's
able to grab the log files
from the custom components
and also from Greengrass
and publish those to Amazon CloudWatch.
Customer support are able
to access those device logs
at any time in CloudWatch.
So it's near real-time logs in the cloud,
all the time, always
accessible to Catapult.
Again, no customer appointment needed,
no burden on the customer anymore
when Catapult need device logs.
I think you know what I'm going to say,
that's good for Catapult,
that's good for their customers.
Okay, one last slide on future outlook.
We've got a lot of benefits
and a lot of functionality
that Catapult are getting
now by having their devices
being cloud-connected, by being
Internet of Things things,
but there's maybe some other things
that they can do as well.
You saw earlier that
the 10 hertz live data
streams only from the
device to the iOS apps
that are on the sideline,
but something that Catapult
are interested in doing
is streaming that data live to the cloud
that can be used for in-game analytics
during matches, during
practice sessions in the cloud,
but it would also enable remote access
for coaches and sports scientists
who are not on the sidelines.
With what Mike showed you earlier,
the ML inference was happening
on the post-processing
after games and after practice sessions
and happening in the cloud.
We didn't go to this detail at all,
but Catapult do have a
small amount of ML inference
happening on the device,
but not a great deal.
They're interested in perhaps shifting
more of that machine learning inference
to the edge on either the
receiver or even the tags
so that these insights can be performed
during games, during practice sessions.
And part of why they're
interested in that now
is the OTA update mechanism
makes this much more feasible.
Previously with Vector 7,
with the inference models
on the edge on the device,
Catapult didn't really have a good ability
to update those, to iterate them,
to enhance them and innovate over time.
Now, because they have OTA update,
they're able to consider
deploying more models to the edge
because they will be able to manage them
and iterate them and enhance them.
And so they can have a true MLOps pipeline
deploying all the way to the device.
They're looking also into AI
analysis of team-wide tag data
in regards to team movements,
players moving as a group
and team tactics,
and also AI for natural
language search of video,
for example, models like
multimodal embeddings models,
which are powerful for that use case.
And that's it, we've arrived at the end.
Mike and I thank you very much
for your attendance and attention.
We'd like to please ask you give
us your feedback in the app.
We'd really appreciate it
if you could take the time to do that.
And if you'd like to
connect with us on LinkedIn,
we would be more than happy to do so.